all right uh let me just check if
everything is working yeah uh seems to
be working edu fun is definitely first
hello everyone uh we are continuing the
kkkd5 christmas arena
it's no longer christmas nor is it
december but there were some problems
and we had to take care of them before
continuing so now
we are unfortunately continuing the
christmas arena in january but it's
better than i guess not continuing it at
all
and uh
well
uh there is still 21 minutes until the
start of the arena so as you can see uh
hikaru is still leading the tournament
as that's where the tournament left off
um there were some other games played uh
after this exact point in time
but this is where the tournament um uh
stopped functioning properly for
everyone and that's why this is the
exact timestamp from where we are
continuing the
the event
deletious team figured that out
everything was nicely explained on
twitter if you guys have seen that now
so this is where we continue so hikaru
has a very solid 11 point lead as you
can see 84 points ahead of alireza who
is currently second then we have rob
feeding master rob in third place from
armenia i believe yeah
magnus in fourth andres penguin fifth
ninja 64 in six that's alexander indige
from serbia uh prague in seventh then we
have seven chess mode also from armenia
uh what uh uh what is this what a
melende uh that's actually opervezen i i
can't pronounce the dutch stuff but yeah
he's uh he's a a pretty pretty legendary
player on leeches and jordan here cake
and space if you if you click on
jordan's name here you can even see that
he has a cake
i don't know if you guys can see it on
stream but there's actually a cake where
you usually put your profile photo so
that's very nice
uh yeah you can see a part of the cake
now i can see it but yeah it's uh it's a
cake
uh and then you have a lot of other very
strong players says most of the top uh
top spots have been taken by by grand
masters
uh so we'll see how it plays out and you
can see uh there are 6 000 players now
and uh last time we were
we were streaming the tournament there
were almost 20 000 players so there has
been like uh
19 19 000 and maybe 500 players but that
was too much for the servers to handle
so now uh we've limited the tournaments
to the rating of 2000 so only if you're
rated 2000 or above you can be you can
uh
well join or continue the tournament
joining at this point doesn't really
make all that much sense even though you
could be paired with a strong player so
you know that that that in itself is a
reward i guess
uh but um
yeah uh some of you some of you have a
blurry image uh it shouldn't be a blurry
image the only way there could be a
blurry image if uh
is my if my internet isn't doing all
that well but
uh yeah usually youtube warns me if uh
there's something wrong with the
connection so it shouldn't be
anything on my side
anthony kennedy you love the dog thanks
man
are all the players who are attending
the tournament coming back yeah
uh hopefully most of them are but not
all of them like i said at least uh you
have to have at least two thousand uh to
play
yeah yeah and the streaks are maintained
whoever had the streak in at this moment
in time will be keeping their streak and
for example hikaru has the streak rob
has the streak magnus has the streak
injeech has the streak prague has the
streak and the the street continues so
no worry about that
uh the the blurry image are probably the
ones with the problem yeah could be
could be an internet thing and then uh
yeah it happens
no magnus is not at my house so only
meadow and myself uh on on this floor
yeah all the best to the participants
all right so we still have some 17
minutes i guess we could uh we could
place some bullet uh before before that
play quality is 144 p uh okay that's uh
that's actually not bad for for chess i
mean you can't really watch anything
else in 144p but you could easily enjoy
chess in 144p
thank you i always hope to be healthy as
well that is that is a great thing to
wish someone
all right uh so if we have any
challenges uh
all right so uh a few bullet games while
we wait i guess that's uh
and um uh some of you said that i should
uh i should use a different kind of a
chess board because let me just fix that
uh because the
the board in my previous stream was a
little bit weird and i actually thought
that was the the original uh board for
leeches but it's not that this is
actually the original board uh or so uh
so it seems
uh all right so let's uh
let's play uh a few bullet games while
we wait
uh to get in to get in the mood it's uh
these games will not be on the level of
the games that uh we will see
uh in the tournament but they will be
enjoyable
all right let's capture here let's
castle a little bit we're gonna play the
pawn here
all right
so we we are trying to be fast not not
uh not to play uh perfect
all right let's capture this okay that's
uh
i can grab this guy here
hopefully oh let's play this it's a it's
a free piece i believe unless i'm
mistaking
yeah it should be a free piece oh that's
nice
that's nice and let's bring this guy
here okay so we we need to play fast now
we can throw in a nice check here to get
a
get a nice past pawn
also the queen can be traded off but
that's fine
okay let's get this guy in
let's get this guy in
okay let's get this guy in
very nice all right let's throw in
another one
all right so we're
doing very well on time
okay maybe even this was possible yeah
i'm gonna do it now
uh like this yeah that's the stuff
all right let's capture grab a queen
i don't wanna waste too much time
thinking
that might not be all that great
oh this is not the original
isn't this the original
no no i i think this is the original
uh let me just check board
is there a board theme
yeah board theme i don't know which one
i'm using
uh but
i'm pretty sure this this is the one
yeah i know pieces are different okay
but i actually like these pieces i mean
they're they're perfectly fine now now
that i have this one and the other one
that i was using the the other one
wasn't all that great
oh it's not the original do any of you
guys know which is the original and some
of you are saying that this is the
original okay so
i guess you are just you're just
trolling me all right so there's a mr
sillett here wants to play a nice rated
game uh
all right usually i prefer non-rated
games on stream let's go e5 here that's
always very dangerous in bullet all
right let's try something like this
okay
just so my bishop doesn't get trapped
let's go get the knight into the game
okay that's very nice
[Music]
okay
weird stuff happening here most
definitely
okay let's uh trade this off let's
capture here
here
and here
no he already resigns okay
okay that was uh that was a very weird
game but that's what we are here to do
all right
mr casual dog no that's a two plus so we
want one plus so
big hello from varadine
mr angry angelo
hello man
all right mr arvind from india while we
wait
the board is zoomed
nope
it should be okay should be okay yeah
all right okay so we have an e4 we're
gonna go for the scandinavian whatever
he does
uh he does not want to play the
scandinavian all right so now we're
playing some sort of a weird setup where
he will
reclaim his pawn okay we do not want
triple pawns
okay let's do this that's a weird thing
to do
i guess he's just going for being really
fast so that's fine okay let's capture
here
let's get our knight in trade we get the
queen in
and
yeah our bishops are nicely placed so
that's that's fine yeah his bishop is
also very nice here okay that's uh
it's very interesting
it's very interesting
can this be played okay what is that
what is that
i have no idea what that is
it's fine i guess let's go here
i think he
just overlooked something a little bit
yeah okay let's go here
all right we take the queen
all right good game man
all right that was uh that was a very
very sneaky one
just read chat yeah sometimes i just
read chat sometimes i don't read chat at
all sometimes but when i read then
people are like don't read the chat you
should you know focus on the games when
i focus on the games and you're not
paying attention to the chat
i had the top of your opponent's clock
is slightly out of view all right uh let
me just uh
see because it it changes when the game
starts so
let me just uh see that one more time
all right uh
let me just check okay when the game
starts
okay the uh
a little bit of the clock is uh let me
just fix that
it could be real quick
to fix this
okay this is the one definitely
all right there we go should we do it
like this a little bit
in this like this all right
[Music]
okay there we go that should that should
improve on it it's not perfect but it
will it will do nicely
alright so i've lost some
30 seconds uh so it's basically hyper
bullet
uh let's let's try for uh for a sneaky
attack yeah because otherwise we're just
going to lose on time
oh that's that's nice i blundered the
knight okay there we go
yep that's the good stuff that's a nice
checkmate today
i love it when that actually works
[Laughter]
alright uh
that was that was very nice
all right mr mr tao principle
all right it's a 7 50 so we still have a
few more minutes until the start of the
start of the tournament
all right there we go
okay we're gonna take that it's a free
piece so
uh i think my opponent is just trying to
be very quick
all right let's go here what is this
what is this all right
let's go here
yeah he is he's very fast but he's down
material so
all right let's go here
okay he did open up the g file but
should not be a problem
uh yeah that'll that'll work nicely
let's trade everything and we are up uh
we are up a bishop so let's use this
bishop wisely
all right so now we're we're in an okay
he doesn't want to play all right
uh that's very nice let me see just uh
seven uh seven minutes and 50 seconds
until the start of the of the arena
so let's
uh my youtube changed to dark mode i'm
not sure i'm the one that changed this
but uh
yeah really weird
uh all right
all right we have criticized all right a
very
very nicely rated opponent
so let's play one against him let's go
for the evans gambit all right he goes
for the evidence very nice let's see if
we can
use our evans magic to do something here
no let's go queen b3 that's uh that's
far deadlier
all right so now he can't play bishop e6
oh the immediate the immediate knight
here all right
very nice
yeah now if he captures the capture if
he plays c6 i moved the bishop somewhere
okay so now i guess we
oh
nice he could even trap my queen maybe
d5 now very nice there goes the pawn
i capture here he'll capture here we
castle maybe some f3 action because the
king is on a very silly square
c6 is hanging so i might even take this
all right let's capture that let's play
f3 okay bishop g5 first maybe
f3 let's open up the f file very nice
all right so he castle somehow he
artificially castled very
successfully um
yeah okay this is uh this is even
good i believe yeah we're gonna capture
on f6
uh if queen e3 rook goes back or i just
go king h1 i'll go king h1 i believe
okay i have to be careful not to get
checkmated here he's uh threatening to
checkmate me so
c4 just to open up
just to open up this diagonal for my
queen d5 let's block the bishop
uh okay yeah we trade here def no we
don't no we don't
huh
queen here
queen f6
okay let's capture this queen f7 oh no
he doesn't allow it
and now knight f6 knight here queen all
right so he lost on time but i i i think
we did very well
and i think this proves that you should
always play the evan's gambit when you
get the opportunity very nice
alright
um
[Music]
all right mr
mr tyrone llama
yes
the evans gambit should be played uh
at every opportunity
b4 is weak yeah
all right we're gonna go for another
scandinavian here uh i just presumed
here he will attack my queen because why
wouldn't he for stream purposes i will
go h5 although that's not a very good
move he'll probably go night here nope i
actually do not have a continuation on
this
i'm just being silly
uh kind of trying to get him to waste
time
okay he captures very nice uh let's go
here
all right so that there's that
definitely
yeah this is hanging so that's uh pretty
annoying
oh oh what is this what is this rook
attacks queen
queen where what is this this wow this
is a
i can't make sense of what's what here
okay so i'm gonna go here attack the
knight and the queen so now he has to
give up the knight otherwise he's
getting checkmated but maybe i can even
maybe maybe i don't have to take the
queen if he captures my rook maybe i
take the rook and still check made him
it's bullet so i might i might just do
that yeah i might not even take the
queen he has to capture the rook maybe
oh he he does it like this very nice all
right yeah i'd do it like that as well
very nice yeah rook captures knight
capture so we go back
so we don't get checkmated uh
all right and now he's down to 10
seconds so not a lot to worry about here
let's go here
yeah just making spend some time that he
doesn't have let's go here let's go here
let's block this
what is this what is this okay let's
block this
check
uh let's go here and that's what i was
hoping for and what
oh he wins the queen back no
i was trying to check made him all right
but we're still doing okay kind of
as long as we don't uh
oh he's trying to flag us with
everything he has so
all right so we flagged him okay that
was a that was a very sneaky game
all right
uh the arena starts in two minutes 34
seconds so i guess we can prepare for
the for the tournament uh we're gonna
start with a uh if he car is playing i
imagine he is playing uh so we're going
to start with uh with a hikaru game and
then we'll see uh
we'll see where the the road takes us
why not take with the knight well it's
uh it's a bullet i wasn't really i
wasn't really thinking
yeah championship is magnus
all right so uh arena starting in one
minute and 55 seconds and since they uh
do not allow anyone above 2000 rating to
join the tournament um uh they assure us
that the tournament will not crash no no
more seventeen thousand players
no no beer today only beer when there
are guests uh
c9c9 is andrew tang
uh
so uh also known as the penguin
likewise mr evan king likewise sritanova
why do i like bullet over blitz i don't
like bullet over blitz i like blitz as
well but when i'm streaming this way i
get to play uh more people so
uh but uh
when i when i actually play i i just you
know warm up with with bullet but then i
i prefer to play blitz yeah like three
minute blitz is is very very enjoyable
[Music]
no whatever lender is operation
uh
vincent uh rothius or rothias or i don't
know how it's pronounced
yeah i like basketball just not very
good at it i was good at it at one point
but that was like maybe 20 years ago
yeah i think anish is also playing uh
i forgot what nickname was anish uh but
could be could be could be
maybe azado um maybe it's azaro but i'm
not sure
yeah i actually knew but i forgot but
but he was playing i don't know if he
will continue playing but he was playing
how old am i at the moment uh 34. all
right so five seconds till the start
let's see yeah let's hope everything
goes smoothly
all right
and there we go all right let's check
out it's icaro versus alireza and
already already a fine clash here
yeah that's a i believe that's a great
game to to start it off with all right
neither of them berserks very nice so
they both want to play as precise a game
as possible but it's really it's tricky
if uh if he if alireza berserks and
hikaru doesn't berserk back that that's
a problem if he was like uh if one
berserks both of them have to berserk
then i i guess he would do it
but here it would be a little bit too
much plus hikaru has the streak so he
has to
also worry about that i'm not sure if if
alireza has the streak
ah the names are a little bit unreadable
yeah i don't know why yeah now that this
is uh let me try to fix this now a
little bit
all right there we go for some reason it
worked
like a moment ago now now it didn't but
yeah that [ __ ] that should do it
all right so hikaru uh definitely
definitely faster but
this is uh
well
it's hard to say maybe maybe alireza but
yeah both of them usually play on
chess.com so i don't think they have
like uh advantage one over another uh
you know regarding the interface so far
only one game they've played and ended
in a draw it was that really quick draw
if you guys remember that everyone was
saying like why would they draw this uh
well you just draw the game and then you
play other games so you don't spend too
much time without getting points
alright so let's see
okay okay hikaru uh does not want a draw
here he plays f5 let's see what happens
ah pawn captures yes hikaru is playing
very very aggressively here very nicely
done
what is this
it was f4 on purpose
[Music]
we'll see
okay hikaru defends nicely even though
alireza's queen has infiltrated
uh all the way
into the position but
how do you continue this there's no way
to continue
what is this
okay so now hikaru just
will probably trade yeah and now he's up
uh uh by a lot
alireza has the bishop's pair but
he's down too much he's down too much
this will be this will be so fast it
will be impossible to follow so let's
see if alireza can do something with
that bishop spare or will hikaru be oh
nice
nice that's why the bishop pair is so
dangerous
nicely done but still
yeah there goes the pawn
all right
so the rook will not okay the pawn is
being pushed and hikaru will now keep an
eye on that pawn
yeah
all right so now maybe hikaru can trick
alireza into into some sort of a
checkmate no it will be a flag off now
hikar will try to flag alireza
and that's how all great games end
but uh if alireza is not playing on his
smartphone then i i think calireza
should be able to hold this
you can see that yeah spends like 0.01
second for each move sometimes sometimes
it slips yeah okay it's a draw it's a
draw
very nicely done very nicely done hikaru
had it but yeah
wow so fast all right let's check
another hikaru game
since uh he is the the the leader
grandmaster shant from from armenia all
right so draw i i can't really remember
if draw loses you the streak but i i
think it does or just uh or just a loss
loses you the streak
yeah can't remember now
no no it was two minutes the last time
as well but it was uh the the first half
of the tournament so everyone was pretty
much berserking
when his new episode of age of kaiser
coming out uh
we'll probably in a few days but we'll
see
am i playing here no i'm i'm not playing
in this tournament this is a tournament
where really really strong players are
playing
is julian playing
maybe i don't know maybe maybe he is
i'm sure he's uh he's watching uh
at some point maybe not the entire
tournament but i don't know all right so
a very nice win by hikaru
uh there's simply not enough uh to
defend all of this all right magnus
grabbed a few wins uh so he is uh
oh he just lost the game oh oh there
goes the streak
another one hikaru versus alireza okay
since now there are first and second now
they'll be playing each other quite a
lot so no easy points for either of them
uh but that's that's what we want so
three draws no two draws so far
uh we'll see is either of them getting a
win against another
yeah magnus seems to have lost
shout out to the doggy yeah
meadow meadows very well used to getting
shout outs
all right so what is happening here
equal material knight against the bishop
if the rooks come of the board but
uh hikaru infiltrated the second rank
with the queen
and now
we'll see
where is the knight coming all right
knight is probably coming to oh yeah
who knows it's too quick
you find you okay that's a nice square
for the night but uh
can the knight ever get there
all right so now now we see the end game
we have uh two minutes to see a
perfectly played endgame
all right so he will
he will wait for f4 at some point but
we'll see
nope he he
decides against this oh
ah okay
it will be hikaru who will go f5 first
very nice very nice
okay oh now hmm
[Music]
and he
what is this
another draw another draw offered
another draw accepted very nice
very nicely done so neither of them
wants to
draw first blood
uh all right
another one by hicaru and then we are
going to to
check out some other games uh he's
playing against grand master chess today
i don't know who that is if any of you
guys are uh
familiar with this
is nipple playing yeah i've i've heard
he's playing and i knew his uh his
handle but
again i forgot if i see it i will know
which one is it
no no i don't think it's narudinsky
that's uh says he's from russia
all right
all right we'll we'll check out a few
more uh we'll check out this one and
then we're going to switch to
the magnus a little bit to see how he's
doing
i don't know how he has less games
played
uh it's uh it's a fair question i i have
no idea
uh the other the other players finished
their games uh quicker i guess
alright so that rook on h6 not
all that impressive
we'll see how how hikaru takes advantage
of
this is ray enigma playing uh
could be could be uh maybe he's maybe
he's also streaming
ah magnus quit like halfway and then he
and then he continued
okay he's max deutsch playing
all right
that that wouldn't be fair to everyone
else if if max deutsch was playing and
yeah dubois is playing as well
all right so
black without a queen and yeah that's uh
that's a resigns all right so maybe we
catch a glimpse of the of the carlson
already game
all right so while it is uh down by
on 28 seconds magnus on one minute but
we already seen how fast alireza is so
28 seconds for alireza is perfectly fine
his king is not doing all that great but
you know who who who could make sense of
this position in in a few seconds
okay
magnus got his pawn to f7 alireza down
to 13 seconds will he be able to save
this one like he did against hikaru
uh
it uh it it seems like he's doing great
with uh yeah
he's spending a second on a move
yeah now magnus will probably trade and
okay 41 seconds is enough for magnus
to win this
oh
that was nice that was nice that was
just a clean rook clean rook very nicely
done bishop attacks rook alireza down on
time off goes the rook and now of course
white is completely winning but if he
hadn't blundered that
that would be great for magnus
all right let's check out okay magnus
versus inju
let's see this
oh yeah now now magnus brokel it is a
streak
is nical playing yeah i think he was
not sure
all right so what's what's what's
happening here
magnus rushing that queen side a nicely
placed king on f2 that's the modern
castling no one castles anymore that's
like uh you know
totally totally pre-co with pre-covet
times
and b5 there there you see good things
happen when you advance that b-pawn
all right rook is under attack
and now he'll just continue harassing
him yeah okay even king g1
for some reason
bishop d4
okay so he's he's trying to play this
very very positionally not interested in
grabbing material
uh because why would you black has uh
very little time and you don't want to
open up the position even if even if
it's a good move i guess
how do you keep players from cheating uh
you can't there is no way to keep
players from cheating but these are very
very known and well strong players so i
don't think any of them would cheat
but there is a there is a system that
detects uh such things
all right 96 very nice
96
okay
ah okay okay okay now if rook captures
it then uh
it's a queen trade yeah i don't think uh
magnus got all that he wanted out of
that one
made thee thanks for the contribution
man
all right so now we have an end game
where uh injury has 30 seconds magnus
says a minute and uh it will not be easy
for injured but
he could hold maybe with 26 seconds
if it's possible
all right
yeah magnus knows what not to do
yeah but i i think magnus will flag him
somehow okay
they are trading pawns
but there is no there is no way to cross
this yeah there is no way to cross c5 no
way to cross g5
uh magnus will have to try something
yeah something to
try and advance this maybe rook g1 g4 or
something but yeah he does he doesn't
want to over push but he wants to
yeah make injury waste time yeah
captures here captures here okay now
it's uh
now it's winning for magnus
okay now the other pawn
very nice
yeah okay uh that's uh it doesn't matter
if you have an equal position against
magnus if you're lower on time yeah
that's
not going to help you okay magnus versus
prague
magnus versus prague
carl reid thanks for the contribution
man
uh what is berserk you give up half of
your time but if you win you get more
points but i don't think anyone will be
berserking anymore i think uh from here
on on uh it will just be you know clean
clean games
hikaru lost all right
yes i i changed my leeches uh board
style because uh a lot of you guys were
saying that this is not the original
board the one that i had in the previous
video and i was i was very sure it is
and then i checked and then it wasn't so
i i
i i guess i thought this was the
original one but now some of you guys
are saying it isn't
uh so
yeah
we'll see but this one is uh well a lot
more a lot more pleasing and easy on the
eyes
uh could i tell me though he's a good
boy maybe you're a good boy
he will he will be petted
nowhere is there
all right
so still equal material
but black
will go after that b2 pawn
nicely defended and now we'll see the
knight oh that's an excellent square for
the knight
and now how to get more out of the
position
now the other rook on the h file the
other rook on g6 probably or maybe not
we'll see
uh
will will will probably withstand this
this vicious attack
what does meadow mean nothing
or rather maybe you know it can mean
bear but
is there a prize yes there are there are
actually three prizes uh
uh compliments of of cake defy
is magnus drunken i i don't think he's
drunk in here
john barnes thank for the contribution
man and and byron swann also thank you
man
all right so uh magnus pushing
knight returns to its wonderful uh
central square
and
okay
nice
so no no trade uh prague knows that with
uh so little time on the clock it would
be pointless to trade queens
and now magnus will just slowly slowly
but surely win this all right
he still doesn't want to push h3 he's
waiting for the perfect moment to
the strike
yeah now now it's perfect as the pawn is
already on f4
and that's pretty much it
yeah he didn't want to capture the queen
due to checkmate
yeah nice a nice attempt to the queen
sacrifice by magnus there
what is this
okay so yeah that that's how he has to
do it
what
oh prago defending very very
impressively here
okay so he doesn't allow queen f7 check
magnus spotted that oh
nice nice nice nice prague fighting
fighting like a beast yeah magnus will
have to flag him
can probably hold this with one second
on the clock
nope oh man that was that was
really wild prague defended like like a
beast with so
so little time on the clock
all right he hikaru is against
cruellarrow and magnus is against
alireza all right you guys will kill me
if i don't show this
all right
well i have some cake during this
session unfortunately i am all out of
cake
but if we have another one of these i
will i will definitely prepare some
yeah it was a dirty flag but that's how
bullet is played when all else fails uh
you flag
oh you'd be surprised what alireza can
hold with one second
[Music]
all right so alireza going after magnus
king on f2 that d4 nicely played uh what
what will magnus uh do here yeah he
didn't want to go e4 probably uh yeah
probably because rook captures on e4
and then um
he will not be able to recapture due to
the fork
but yeah
liam zackson thanks for the contribution
man favorite thing about croatia
it's uh it's very clean it's very clean
okay so alireza picks up the queen and
now uh also connects nicely with the
bishop here and the magnus is now forced
to resign so uh big win for alireza
taking away the streak from magnus and
now no one has this three streak from
the top three
uh vincent rotharis is uh catching up to
them very nicely who is hikaru playing
mad pro
all right
let's check the end game on this one
will anish get the prize if he draws all
games uh we would we would uh think of a
prize for for an issue just for that
uh that would be uh that's uh easier
said than done i mean
you can't be sure that you're gonna draw
all the games someone might uh
might resign you you'll be playing for
two hours and then someone will resign
and that's it
yes this is two plus so without any
increments
all right so hikaru uh sacrificing the
pawn to get uh grab hold of this pawn
and now he's completely winning
so very nicely done
is there a bullet brilliant surprise uh
no but we'll definitely add one uh in
the future
all right magnus vs jordan
jordan always wins at least one prize in
my tournament so
let's see if he can if he can also do it
here
okay uh
mate being defended by the rook
queens are off
wow you're the jordan super fast
you're the berserk magnus ho ho
you you're then berserked magnus
okay magnus
has a very nice pawn but so does jordan
how can
how can you order them play this f7
covered
yeah he
okay
king e6 no
oh with check with check and now jordan
will lose because he's down on 10
seconds but oh he tricked magnus wow
nope he didn't no he didn't
what do you do here how do you defend
why jordan plays this uh he played like
the last five moves with 10 seconds on
the clock very impressive
very impressive and he gets a draw
nicely done
all right who is magnus playing jigalco
all right two of them have played like a
million games together already but here
uh it says they've played zero because
magnus always changes his uh his handle
hey manny shrestha welcome to excellent
subscribers man
magnus is probably drunk no i don't
think he is i don't he's not gonna just
drink
every tournament i i think that's only
for when he streams
yeah magnus exclusively plays the blonde
cloud it would seem
because it's just such a such strong
opening
yeah he's uh
he's he he's weird like that
because if you know it's it's actually a
really good uh opening idea for magnus
because if he
if he doesn't win you know it's because
he played the bomb cloud in every game
if he does win he's just that much
better than everyone else so it you know
it's it's a win whatever you do
what are the prizes for the tournament
uh they're they're actually listed on
the tournament uh on the tournament page
oh nicely played f5 very nice jigalco
loses that bishop but will win that
queen very nice
all right so can can magnus
okay the bishop the rook uh everything
is nicely uh hitting that uh
g7 square
uh
okay
bishop b5
can you
can you make use of this somehow okay of
course you okay
now 97 picks up the rook if he
if he gets it but if he doesn't then
[Music]
yeah many many dangers here
oh that's very nice
okay very interested to see what magnus
will find here no he trades rooks
which is not great for him
maybe
bishop f1 okay
okay so he he manages to trade pretty
much everything off
and now he has to prevent uh yeah he has
to prevent all the checks so he doesn't
lose material
[Music]
and now how does he
no it's not gonna happen
not gonna happen magnus will lose this
one
yeah now that uh pawn is marching down
and that's it
yeah maybe if it was a dark square
bishop
it'd be possible
but i mean maybe he maybe he pulls it
off we'll see
uh geppetto's nipple yeah so i've heard
so i've heard
he carries on a losing streak
all right so everyone beating everyone
here
that's that's the good stuff
uh no i don't think magnus played hikaru
yet in this tournament i could be wrong
but i don't think they played
okay and magnus resigns here there's no
no point in continuing this very nicely
done
and magnus drops the sixth place
behind vincent ortiz but uh you know
that's what happens when you play the
hanson on twitch is this uh eric hansen
versus hikaru
could be yeah could be
maybe it's not but uh
i don't know
they usually play on the under chest bra
but uh maybe it is him
yeah his car is still first yeah i mean
magnus just lost yeah
this is uh this is two plus so this is
no one is safe here because everyone
everyone hates this time control it's
not one plus so it's not three plus so
it's two plus so and uh
well it's just ugly
all right hikaru gets getting bullied
here
a lot he car really getting bullied here
and hanson not interested in a draw okay
now he now he resigns very nice
very nicely done hanson beats hikaru
now hikaru loses another one
who is alireza playing okay versus
hikaru yeah let's let's enjoy that
ah
eric hansen is playing under chess bra
okay okay
ah this could be neiman okay
all right ah
so this is the third game between them
all games so far ended in a draw
all right
yeah happy birthday to evanesco
definitely happy birthday vanessa hope
you uh had had a good one and you know
hope you get to play or all the
fortnites today you want
yeah this is the second time i'm hosting
this because the first one did not end
so well
okay he car piling up on that f6
pawn uh
how will alireza play this it's a wow
it's a really
really disgusting position
uh
there's no good way for black to make
moves yeah that's just uh just a
nonsense move that doesn't do anything
all it is is pretty much forced to move
that rook up and down
and there's really no no move you can
make but it seems to be enough
yeah okay there's there's the little
knight jump also possible
yeah
this is great how how how many
uh useful moves can you make here okay
it's interesting alireza gives up that
pawn to make some progress
uh
i don't know looks looks very
intimidating if those pawns start
marching down the board
but i guess he will try to hide the king
maybe on the queen side yeah
uh how did i manage to get all the gms
uh well
it wasn't easy i called every one of
them personally and i requested that
they show up on the tournament that's
how i did it
yeah my magnus is born clouding everyone
yes
all right so uh seems uh
seems like made it out of that mess and
with decent time on the clock so it's
it's it's amazing what what he he can do
but now that bishop is
oh
okay
offering a queen trade yeah now now uh
hikaru's best hope is the
you know win on time and harass that uh
sorry alireza's
to harass hikaru's king and hikaru will
try to use uh that pawn to win
but you know with the king that wide
open i don't think it's happening
yeah it's very very very ugly
20 seconds for earlier he will now try
to
to do what exactly
yeah you can't go to the back rank if
you go here quincy for oh even that
okay now he will try to flag him if it's
possible okay if not
um
yeah i think i think he already found
the draw i i think he already found the
draw
if it if it exists
and now
now he now hikaru resigns
very nice
oh sorry alireza resigns uh that that's
it
all right three losses in a row for
alireza hikaru finally get to win and
now we have hikaru versus magnus now we
have hikaru vs magnus and magnus goes
for the for the bomb cloud yes
he goes for the bomb cloud
no berserks so it's going to be a long
one
and by long i mean two two minutes
all right so
can hikaru take down the bomb cloud
all right
oh very nice very nice
very nice magnus resigns here
because he hung the queen
okay so that was a there was a slap in
the face for magnus hikaru takes a nice
one
uh
fandoreen
okay hikaru vs gm fandurin from russia
uh don't know who that is if any of you
guys know uh so uh
i don't uh i mess around with the with
the
screen yeah that was uh that was a
painful one for magnus yeah
all right knight f6 very nice
uh both of them berserked so hikaru now
two down magnus in a few moves now he
feels very comfortable
and is starting to berserk
how many players are oh very nice very
nice because king captures queen
captures knight and then rook h8 and
that's it
uh very nicely done
all right
jaco jacob baby from uzbekistan is also
doing very well here
who do we have alireza cornevlad all
right alireza versus artemiev
have some sort of a some sort of a
well some sort of a london system with
f6 g5 obviously
uh
with the g5 h5 artemia is really going
uh going uh
all out here
but alireza not very impressed he is
just making moves he has more time than
artemiev
yeah no magnus is not leaving the bomb
cloud he said he will play the bomb
cloud and he's playing the bomb cloud no
no messing around with magnus
all right
you just joined what's going on well we
still have 46 more minutes to this great
tournament so
uh
we'll see we'll see what happens uh
currently hikaru is still leading and
alireza magnus and a lot of other strong
players are trying to catch up to him
but hikaru just keeps keeps crushing
everyone
why is still under uh
the flag of iran uh i don't know i guess
uh lee chess never changed that yeah
yeah leeches you should definitely
change this alireza is still playing
under the flag of iran
all right
oh he's not he's not interested in the
pawn
but he will grab it yeah oh quinca okay
maybe he should have went for the pawn
right away but
we'll see is bishop to e7
no
sorry bishop to d2 is that is that a
move
yeah that's that's a threat no no reason
to to push it
all right
wow this is uh this is so intense just
watching this is so intense
so the queen has to move away and then
queen captures on g3 will happen if the
queen does not defend that
so
uh alireza will have to figure out how
to keep defending this
is queen e5 check even a move
nope that's just the blunder yeah he has
to figure out how to play this
okay
yeah he had to make room for the queen
on this diagonal
but that's it
okay so now he's going into uh into a
much worse end game where
wow artemis just completely crushed him
completely crushed him beautiful
that's uh
that was not uh easy to watch
hikaru versus t clock but this game is
over
uh azado versus uh
yaakov baby i don't know who that is do
you guys know who yaakov baby is from
uzbekistan
is it one of the
the strong players from uzbekistan we've
uh we've seen in the world rapid and
blitz
yeah artemy have uh really really crush
this yeah who is yakko baby
yeah azaro could be a niche but i'm not
sure
yeah
i'm pretty sure it's one of them as they
are all from uzbekistan i was asking if
anyone knows
for sure
all right
so putting a lot of pressure on a player
that may or may not be a niche
uh but some of you are saying it is
so you know
uh it's a very nicely placed pawn there
although uh you you are down a rook so
there's also that
oh nice nice nice nice but the queen
escapes and now you are threatening
threatening some very nasty meeting
ideas with rook h1 and queen somewhere
wow this is so ugly so ugly for a niche
am i organizing this tournament yes uh
i'm organizing it with the with the
sponsorship from from kd5 yeah
yeah it's basically a belated christmas
gift yeah
all right so what is this this bishop is
okay queen captures bishop no
i thought queen captures bishop rook
captures rook
um
wow
wow wow
okay and he resigns he he over pushed it
he over pushed it and he resigns very
nicely done
so uh anish uh closes in under on the
top ten but
it will be hard to catch up to hikaru uh
yako baby doing a very very nice job of
this
uh who is okay we don't know uh artemiev
also in third place very nicely playing
against rob uh
that's uh
naruditsuki alireza dropped the six all
right so who do we watch who do we watch
okay let's check out hikaru
uh i'm trying to trying to get a game
when it started but as it's a bullet you
know
as soon as you click they've already
played like 15 moves
yeah overthink and throw the win
no i did not i did not personally invite
anyone as everyone is uh everyone who
was invited to the tournament
is a common name in uzbekistan
yeah he didn't care all that much about
this
uh
about this uh captures on f5 and then on
g6 but we'll see what he's
who is who is international master of
book zero zero
anardis broke into third
wow
uh for the moment i'm not uh preparing
any any twitch streams uh but i am
preparing uh
uh for those of you who still don't know
i am preparing a chess quiz or rather a
trivia i still don't know the difference
between a quiz and the trivia is just a
different word uh but yeah i'm preparing
a chess quiz you know that where
everyone will be able to join and i've
found a nice interface where you will be
able to use youtube chat to type in your
answers and you will be you know
fighting against each other so
uh stay tuned for that
all right b4 as you can see always
winning b4 very nicely done by hikaru
how long left for the tournament 40
minutes you can still join and you know
reach the top ten no no worries you just
have to berserk everything and here
black resigns of course
uh
well he just lost everything
all right so
naruditsuki uh
and artemiev in all right giri artemyev
let's see what they're doing
so it's sort of uh okay equal-ish
equalish end game but uh you know
material-wise
so of course uh anish will oh he will
trade queens
i thought he might not because he he
controls
a bit more but they know what they're
doing worry not
what is anisha's handle as azara 25
where did magnus go
who knows
okay
[Music]
did magnus rage quit no i don't think uh
i don't think he rage quit maybe he just
quit i don't think he would would rage
uh about such a thing
but you never know
okay thank you for the for the very
insightful answers regarding the quiz
and the trivia
uh
very i appreciate it
will i make more videos like i did for
the evans gambit you mean opening
tutorials
uh probably not too many
uh i did a few of them i did like a
couple of tutorials i did a tutorial on
the evans gambit i did the
one on the scandinavian defense
um i did the one i think on the bishop
and the knight in the game and maybe on
the
yeah i don't know i'm pretty like i made
like five five tutorials
and no more uh but i will have to you
know
group them at some point and uh make
like a like a little tutorial bundle
yeah meeting with the bishop at night
yeah i remember i made that one
uh who who would remember i made like 3
000 videos
yeah to london yeah the london
no how to play against the london yeah
that queen b6 line yeah that's a
that's a that's a sneaky one okay and we
have a draw here
right so who is hikaru playing next
never enough i actually knew who this
was but i can't remember
jakub versus alireza
special prize for the best game uh with
the evans gambit uh well of course the
the the prizes they will get their game
shown on the channel uh but it's hard to
say i mean someone must have played the
evidence gamble but there are too many
games being played and uh
i don't know if there's like a system on
leeches that you know you can use to
search this and it's a nice draw no way
to cross this very nice all right let's
check out another one
uh yakko baby versus esipenko all right
very nice clash very nice clash
can i make a hoodie guys saga we already
have a kind of a hoodie guys saga i mean
all of the hoodie guys videos that i
made unfortunately i don't have a hoodie
guy playlist so i'm gonna
have to make it at some point
because i'm pretty sure i have like at
least 30 videos with the hoodie guy
maybe even 50 i don't know
maybe not 50 okay maybe 30.
all right
yeah wouldn't make sense to capture on
f5 on f7
will the quiz be hard for 1200s no i
don't think
your rating will help you in this quiz
i'm making it's going to require some
vast knowledge on your part
so first quiz will be 50 questions all
about paul charles murphy i'm of course
only kidding
but that might make for an interesting
quiz one day just to see how well you've
followed the morphe saga
alright so
there's a lot of stuff happening on the
queen side
and on the king side so this is one one
messy game
all right captures captures
a breakthrough there
on the king side and
a nice check
it's uh also upon sacrifice
to get the knight into the game
and now
yeah
i think uh
okay
so black is going all out here black is
going all out here he's sacrificed and
now he wants to take down uh the king
but how will how will he reach the king
that's the question
it's not easy
and uh
there doesn't seem to be a way
what queen captures and then what
okay
very nice the queen is overloaded
okay now the queen is hanging the rook
is hanging okay
jakub baby fans finds a very nice
counter play
i'm not saying any weird words that i
don't know
what they mean
okay what is this what is this very nice
king moves rook captures h8 game over
wow
oh
he took down esipenko just like that
very nice and uh he could be closing in
on hikaru he he doesn't have the streak
anymore but the knight was hikaru akiko
playing naraditsuki here seems like sort
of a weird position where
where hikaru just won a queen and will
we see a resigns here yeah we see your
resigns here okay but by hikaru
anardisky nardiski won the queen nicely
done
so hikaru takes the loss or
am i just seeing things wrong did hikaru
win this
yeah that was really weird no no he lost
this one yeah it's just that the the
interface is uh much much slower at
showing this
geppetto versus cicla
naraditsuki versus i don't know who this
is corny blood drop stone
all right let's check out the game from
the leader
zaven chess mood
yeah it seems that he lost yeah he seems
that he lost
all right so an ugly position for for
black definitely
but we'll see how hikaru how how he car
plays this
he piles up
zaven piles up on that
uh
a6 pawn but uh it seems that it's not
very relevant
putting pressure
all right
now for those of you who are saying that
quality is 144 p you have to switch it
from auto you have to move it from auto
you have to choose the resolution
yourself and then the resolution will
improve
all right so what do we have here pawn
is nicely protected now the other pawn
falls and all of a sudden
all of a sudden he carries up a pawn
just like that there you go
there you go just like that
it's a double spawn but oof
is is up on time what is this oh
he car wins another one that was that
was brutal that was brutal okay do we
see another one
[Music]
okay against the akko baby all right
let's see hikaru versus nothing
okay okay
all right someone someone in the chat
saying go yako
well he's obviously very strong if he if
he almost
caught up to hikaru with 30 minutes left
to the
tournament
uzbekistan is having some
very very strong players lately and you
know in in a year i believe it's going
to be
well
the the
the amount of power at the top will be
uh distributed very very differently i
think
yeah yeah yucca toddler no no
did i see venom too no i i i stopped
watching marvel movies after uh after
avengers end game now i'm waiting for
them to make like 10 or 15 more and then
i'm gonna watch all 15 at once
uh that's kind of kind of my plan
hey bixty thank you for dropping in man
all right so hikaru nicely pushing those
queen side pawns
but he is down a piece but i i don't
think it matters those three pawns are
definitely worth the piece
one of my favorite games is uh
braunstein versus neidorf where
brunchten gives up a piece to push the
three side pawns just like this
it's actually very similar
yeah a lot of a lot of you guys are
saying that you also stopped after end
game
yeah but there's so much there's too
much to watch and
i'm just you know when they make them
like
then i'm gonna watch them
probably i don't know
i hope so
all right so hikaru uh
not
not
doing all that great now i i've looked
at the chest for like a second then all
those pawns are gone
now it's uh two rooks against the rook
and bishop and hikaru still has his past
pawn but i don't think it will matter
here
uh
and yakube is extremely fast so i don't
think hikaru will be able to flag him
so we'll see
with perfect plate probably a draw but
you know it's it's a bullet
okay hikaru doesn't allow king g5
but he can't uh control the a3 pawn and
the g5 square there goes the a3 pawn
and now
we'll see we'll see if he has the
technique to to get this done in 25
seconds
in bullet
okay very nice
very nice
huh
what do you do here
not your king thanks for the
contribution man
hashtag 992 doesn't mean anything it's
my it's my blizzard battle tag
i i just uh put it in one of my videos
and uh it remained there so you know i i
just left it there
all right so yeah it's a draw it's a
draw of course he car will not try to
flag anyone here
uh so
yeah the the interface does not update
all that quickly
but no you guys are saying geppetto is
nippo where but it says here italy
are you guys tricking me
no no hikaru did not lose that one no no
it was a draw
magnus was playing yeah magnus was
playing but it seems that he after
losing a few games decided to call it
call it a day
aha it's a different gepetto that is
nepo
have i ever fall the victim to a
trolling of course
of course many many times
amagnus is still playing okay okay
no because a lot of you guys were saying
magnus left so that's why i thought
all right so here
uh
yeah very very nicely done about five
seconds on the clock uh yeah
yeah this will be a clean flag a clean
flag
yeah very clean flag gm wins
all right so who do we have okay who's
he carol playing sparta okay it's a nice
nice wild position let's let's check
this out
sparta going after hikaru i knew who
sparta was now i don't anymore
yeah japeto is pinocchio's father that
is true that is true
yeah
max deutsch undercover
now if max deutsch uh joined the
tournament no one would no one would
have fun
all right so hikaru putting a lot of
pressure on that f file
uh
what uh what uh what a brilliant
sacrifice this was
and he resigns yeah
check and he resigns very nicely done
all right
artemia is playing penguin all right
let's see artemia versus penguin
so many games so little time
sort of like like a venom quote but i i
still haven't seen venom two
all right
artemia has an excellent score against
penguin as you can see it's 13 to four
so far
so
a nice opportunity for penguin to get
back at him
penguin is a grandmaster andrew tang
yeah no it's not kevin sprague no
all right so white hopes to continue
pushing that h pawn
and black will try and use this uh
beautiful bishop and queen to do some
damage
but how
that is the question artemis not
impressed
andrew andrew keeps pushing that h pawn
now we'll see we'll see how to play this
with black and should black be afraid of
the past h pawn
yeah some of the games are
are funny like when magnus plays the the
bomb claw but this is a very very
serious game
so here okay so now he can capture with
the pawn
okay very very
very intense
corner vladis vladislav
the the legend
does anyone actually know who rey enigma
is
is it like uh like one of the greatest
secrets of the universe
[Music]
all right going after that f7 square
check and okay the bishop now nicely
blocks this and now black will
try something but how do you get the
rook into the game okay now you can
maybe get the rook nope nope not anymore
so trading queens here is the only thing
for black yeah
but he's still gonna try something okay
threatening checkmate
check
you can't move the bishop
wow he finds a move so quickly
artemis so quick with the move and now
he defends wow he found such a nice
series of moves to get to that point
away from the bishop it's incredible
wow i i okay now now rook
rook g5 yeah check and now black will be
winning this very nice
and he's extremely fast i don't think
even penguin oh almost checkmated him if
he didn't play g4 almost checkmated him
but can penguin flag him maybe he can
okay i think yeah andrew is so fast yeah
i think he's flagging him successfully
even without wow okay and penguin flags
are tamiya nice
nicely done wow
incredible
incredible
oh it's hikaru versus giri
hikaru versus giri
in uh what do we have here
equal material but a very unequal
position
yeah penguin is the fastest what are you
going to do
ahikar thinks ray enigma is an
international master not a grandmaster
so definitely possible
definitely possible
will alireza beat carlson in 2023 and
become the the youngest world champion
ever well he first has to win the
the candidates which is uh
no small feat
and then we can discuss such things okay
g4 why why that
very interesting
okay and they agree to a draw
so a nice gentlemanly super gm draw okay
another car versus alireza and we we
caught it right from the start
what is this was this some sort of yeah
it was some sort of berlin
and
all right
let's let's enjoy it
re-enigma is the ghost of alekhine
no dog gets plenty of pets meadow is uh
no no one gets more pets than meadow
yeah it has it down to 11. what do you
what are you gonna do i mean this is a
it's a crazy tournament
maybe yeah but okay uh
i i don't know what's the and there is a
berserk here yeah he has to start
berserking
but then you berserk and then you lose a
few games and then it's
uh would nipple be a win uh against
magnus in the world championship if uh
if he played the evan's gambit well his
chances would definitely be much much
greater
all right so here will we have another
draw or will hikaru win another one
alireza is up a pawn but as usual he
berserked and he is down too much on
time
so we'll see
yes meadow is defeated grand dog
all right it's a
free pawn but hikaru will now probably
do some sort of a checkmate
oh this is very intense very intense
okay now there is a nope
hikaru very happy with his position
now hikaru not even allowing the draw
now now he wants a win
yeah
now he wants a win nope
okay now eight seconds is plenty for
alireza to draw this so i don't think he
has to worry here
okay so very nicely drawn very nicely
drawn
uh
japeto esquired yako baby msb drop stone
versus dimitri hikaru
all right let's continue with hikaru as
he is he still has a 13 point lead so he
car is still playing incredibly
impressively here
do i know the lineup for the tata still
i i'm pretty sure it's it's made been
made public
so far they've played two times only
chess and hikaru both won the games
oh there is a missed mate in one oh
that's a shame that's shame
will croatia have a world champion it's
uh i think after you know the the
like in a few years where when maybe
magnus will not be number one and we're
gonna have a complete shift of power at
the top uh i don't think anyone can even
imagine who will be at the top well
players like uh who are just you know up
and coming very young
uh so i think there will be so many of
them uh we might not see uh a clear
favorite like we have magnus now so it
might be just a total scramble all the
time
but we'll see
will will magnus be the last
clear clear champion
all right
what is this
yeah you can't go after the pawn because
the b7 pawn falls and then
yeah but okay he called up on time he he
should not have any problems playing
this
ahmed yusuf thanks man thanks for the
for the compliment
in 2026. okay
i mean
uh
the they're all incredible players but
uh classical is a is a totally different
beast from
from uh rapid or or blitz so
i don't know
we'll see we'll see if the classical
even remains the the the you know main
format to
decide the best player in the world
all right i'm pinning here now a little
check maybe new
[Music]
yeah check definitely check now we have
to be careful
yeah i can't capture the pawn because
knight c7 picks up the rook
but what now what can hikaru go for now
uh yeah we know rebecca harris is
narudicky
fork miss no i don't uh was there a fork
i was constantly looking and then i
looked at the chat and now you guys
saying a fork mist
all right
chris pantel thank you for the
contribution man
and for the for the kind words all right
pinning the knight nicely done attacking
the rook
oh
now up upon
oh it's not going to be easy for hikaru
but he is up on time
what now what now
all right now hikaru losing some time
nice hair thank you thank you
okay that's a very nasty past pawn
that's a nasty past pawn
oh
nice
rookie eight wow rookie eight brilliant
brilliant and hikaru takes this one nice
nice what uh what a fine clean shot
rookie eight
all right what do we have 11 more
minutes in the tournament
uh prague is playing geppetto it's a
it's a
clean position
bensie thanks for the contribution man
and thanks for for sticking so long
with us
yeah that was a that was a big brain
moment for hikaru definitely definitely
everyone is so high rated like these
guys are twenty nine hundred three
thousand thirty one hundred
uh i don't know i think magnus in some
format got even to thirty three hundred
gb brought welcome to excellent
subscribers man welcome to the to the
club
and thanks for the contribution pedi
pedi
sorry i'm blind petty mullins
[Music]
all right geppetto loses prague wins
this one very nicely because after queen
captures bishop queen uh to f8 will be
checkmate nicely done by prague
uh okay hikaru versus someone who we
don't know who it is uh geppetto versus
magnus all right so magnus playing one
of the leaders
so
i think magnus is getting back into it
we'll see we'll see what happens is oh
yeah it was again the bong cloud
you can see the king is on f2 very
nicely done
what rating do i think i could get to
well uh i don't know if i did any work
at all
i'm pretty sure i could get maybe maybe
um 20 2400 i think i could i could do if
i had like uh you know
uh if that was the only thing i did but
who knows if i had if i had a great
teacher if i could uh you know devote
enough time i i have no idea
crossland beer thanks for the
contribution man
always always love to hear such such
wonderful stories where where people got
into into chess
all right magnus takes this one very
nicely done and is magnus back in the
top 10
not yet no magnus is not in the top 10.
okay he car was still uh struggling with
that unknown gentleman
yaakov baby versus drop stone but that's
the end of the game coney vlad versus
geppetto all right
let's see how artemiev does this
uh when is uh the chess brings together
people video coming out uh very very
soon very soon
uh i don't want to give an exact date
but within a week or maybe maybe two
weeks
i'm not making it myself so you know it
takes as long as it takes it's not uh
sometimes during january
nice
thanks for the contribution manish gupta
and jd goldball thanks man
all right so what do we have here
uh opposite color bishops uh equal
material only it's not bla white is up
upon
uh we'll see can can artemis make
something of this pawn
all right definitely looking like it it
should be possible
yeah so now he's gonna push d6 that
create no he's not okay he first has to
defend e3
yep
that's why these guys are good and i'm
blind
i did not even see that was hanging
bruno rosa thanks for the contribution
man
uh
and now those two past pawns are just
killers
oh ho
with tempo b6 with tempo that's why you
should never allow your rook to be uh
attacked with tempo wow what is this
what is this madness rk1
wow
rookie one
and uh artemi resigns very nicely done
very nicely done yeah
wow
there's no defense no defense against g
pawn to g2
that was that was very clean
carl finishing his game with x choir
georg meyer is playing all right yakko
baby versus penguin this will be this
will be a treat
sometimes you hear me saying captures
captures when you're sleeping that's uh
i call this great success
oh
what oh
yoko baby blunders a knight wow
man you can't even look at the chat for
a second
uh hikaru okay against the bmw hero
no idea who that is but he's playing
under the leeches flag
yeah that was a pretty bad blunder
how does the how does it feel when the
best players in the world are playing my
tournament uh
feels very natural to
tell you the truth uh but um
i'm just very happy we were able to to
get all of these players together uh
especially now okay in in december it
was uh
pretty crazy with everything that was
happening and we barely managed to
squeeze it in in between the world rapid
and bliss championship but now uh we
kind of had this one date because
players now again have to pack they have
to you know start flying to the tata
steel tournament uh that's
going to be played next week uh so it's
uh pretty crazy but i'm glad we were
able to organize this one
yeah the the only problem is that we
can't see all the games at once but
i'm sure at some point we will have
technology available that will allow us
to enjoy all of them
some sort of a neural interface that
will you know allow such a thing
all right bishop d5 and now we'll see
now we see what what hikaru has in store
here
can he make something of that extra pawn
or
is the bishop pair just too mighty
all right
let him let him roll it out
i andrew already closed the top three oh
no uh you already left yeah
he was he was hoping to to win the prize
but maybe now he he figures that with
four minutes it's uh too late
thanks for the contribution man
can i touch my ankle and say sorry about
that
all right
uh now bishop e5 yeah no
yeah you have to bring the king closer
now bishop to e5 can be played and that
could be very dangerous yeah now it
can't okay
so now white grabs a pawn
and now it will be another flag off
stranded on a deserted island with
hikaru or magnus
uh it's it's a tough one i have nothing
to to base my answer on
as i've never uh you know hung out with
either of them
but uh if i had to choose i i would go
with magnus you know just so so i could
say i i i was uh you know with a world
champion on a deserted island
sounds sounds kind of cool
other than that i don't have a a metric
that i would base my answer on
rob we says i had to drown myself
yeah okay
fair
all right and hikaru wins this uh as
being
a bmw hero
resigns with a few seconds on the clock
so here
uh we have two more minutes uh
two more minutes on the clock he car
still with an 11 point lead but penguin
dangerously close although he i don't
think he can yeah he can't win 11 points
uh
even if he like super berserks
everything but he's not even berserking
hey cheers from florida kb thanks man
for the contribution
do i feel anand is underrated when
people talk about the greatest players
it's it's very hard to say it's very
hard to say because anand is uh
anand is in between gary kasparov and
the magnus carlsen and kasparov left
left on his own and then you know uh
magnus came i don't know
it's hard to say
but in in his prime he was definitely
the strongest that's what that's what
matters
are playing for third place
all right
i i think penguin is second regardless
of of what happens but uh being second
in in such an event i mean that's uh
that's incredible i mean i know penguin
is extremely strong in uh bullet and
hyper bullet but two plus so i didn't
think he would do so well so this is uh
this is really incredible
always always happy to see andrew
playing well
all right he's down upon
and i i guess this is a draw yeah of
course he gives him a draw even with 16
seconds
and we have 18 more seconds in the
tournament so uh okay hikaru is not
playing one more game
uh we're gonna check out uh
one more probably
just for the for the fun of it before we
proclaim the winners
uh all right uh
is there any possibility of uh no there
isn't i think that's it
yeah okay that's it
so this uh this tournament comes to an
end and these are the top ten i hope you
guys can see this
uh so the winner is uh tsm fdx hikaru uh
with a very nice performance of 3152
points with a berserk rate of 36 percent
and 56 games played second place andrew
tang uh also known as penguin um uh
penguin uh i am although even though
he's a grandmaster now uh playing from
antarctica as you can see uh and third
place gm dropstone uh i don't know if i
know who this is maybe i know maybe i've
checked david paravian okay
i know i know him i just didn't know
that was him so congratulations to
everyone as it says here in the
description i will now contact after the
stream contact everyone and make sure
that you are uh eligible and able to
receive your prizes and now uh all right
we have fourth pla fourth place yakov
baby uh fifth place geppetto of artem
even sixth uh uh this is uh rothaus
vincent in seventh uh night king 96 in
eight uh what neg in ninth mood pro uh
in tenth and then uh the other ten are
rebecca harris pragnanda esquire uh dr
championstein uh
aka magnus then uh ninja64 that's
injuican space 16 elm 2007 uh 17 a
candidate master amongst all of these
gm's so very very impressive they even
chess mode sparta 299 and rob 188 with
so many other players uh it's very
unfortunate that we had to cut the first
tournament short because it would be
incredible to finish the tournament with
20 thousand players instead of seven but
uh you know uh what are you gonna do
uh so yeah uh that's uh it for this one
hope you guys enjoyed it and that uh you
know uh we we did everything uh properly
like i said uh very sorry the the
tournament broke down the first time but
i guess the world simply does not have
the technology required to host such a
big tournament yet but maybe maybe in a
year or two we can host a a really big
one
uh so uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh the the players will now
be contacted uh you know regarding the
the receiving of the prizes and uh yeah
that's pretty much it if you haven't do
check out uh
some of my videos today that i've made
uh they're very nicely
uh they're they are very enjoyable i
i've enjoyed making them very much and
yeah that's it thank you all for coming
and i will see you soon uh with uh
hopefully some more tournaments i might
be doing some more streams and yeah like
i said i will be making a chess quiz uh
you know so you guys will be able to
participate and uh you know uh show off
your great uh vast knowledge in front of
everyone so yeah that's it uh have an
excellent rest of your day guys and see
you soon